Speaker 1: I want to look at another
set of clips from of various meetings,
school board meetings, municipal meetings around
the country where anti maskers and anti vaccines
will not stop humiliating themselves. And there is
a bigger concern here, and it is one of how easily
so many Americans can be radicalized into
all sorts of different nonsense beliefs. And
what I mean by that is it's easy to look at
these people and to say this is just someone
who's bonkers about vaccines, that's just a
person who's bonkers about comet ping pong.
And this is someone who believes Kuhnen or
whatever the case may be. There is a bigger
problem, which is that for a lot of these people,
they would be sucked in delusional to something.
It's not actually only about one thing. It just
happens to be this is the one thing that was in
the news right now and that got them. And it's the
rise of conspiracies and the rise of gullibility,
the rise of ignorance and the lack of critical
thinking skills that is rampant in this country.
So let's just jump right into the first one.
Here's a woman who claims to be a registered
nurse with two kids. Again, a lot of these folks
are delusional even about their own circumstances.
I don't know whether this is really a nurse. I
don't know whether she really has kids. She said
in Florida to the Lee County School Board that
they are demonic entities because of either masks
or vaccines or something. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: My name is Melissa. I have
two daughters in the school system,
Speaker 1: so she's already crying. She's so
overcome with emotion. She's already crying.
Speaker 3: These are demonic entities and
we need to stick together. Remember,
we have authority and Christ, Jesus,
these are demonic entities and all the school
boards of all the United States of America
and all of us Christians will be sticking
together to take them all out on the police
officers that kick us out for our First
Amendment right. We'll also be going
down with them. Do you understand?
Speaker 1: No, I don't understand.
I don't know what she's talking about.
Speaker 3: I'm a nurse. Infectious disease,
13 years math. Don't work. These doctors
that sit up here that we're sneering at us,
looking at us like we're scumbags. They need to go
back to fucking medical school and you're out of
order. And please, this is your last warning.
Speaker 1:
Now, the bike seems to have
been cut off communications.
Oh, some nasty audio feedback there.
Speaker 3: They need to remember
natural immunity is best. You all demonic entities
maybe playing to be taken a scam. If the body had
your first warning and this is your
last. She cannot speak anymore.
Speaker 1: So that's serious mental illness. We're
not joking around. We're not saying she's crazy.
That is an individual completely disconnected
from reality. So what do we do about it? Is
is the problem. And I don't want to just write it
off and say this is we only need to think of this
as a mental health situation. But this is clearly
someone who's not well. And she also is just wrong
about a lot of facts. How do we deal with that?
Here's another one. This is painter Scott Brady,
who showed up to the Springfield,
Pennsylvania school board meeting
in a hazmat suit because his daughter has
to wear a mask and something about Hitler
Speaker 2: where they don't do nothing, they
don't do enough. In 1985 outbreak in which a
monkey with a virus, they were hazmat crews, t AP
came down, they quarantined the whole house. They
had hazmat suits on. What do you have short term
memory loss? Because I think, you know, first of
Speaker 1: all, they I think used
to couldn't say it any better.
Speaker 2: Oh, she certified those
measures. Are they certified by the FDA,
those bastards and everybody else?
Speaker 1: No, I don't I actually don't
think this is Joe Paci. At one point
I thought this was actually Joe Paci
doing the my Cousin Vinny character in a hazmat
suit. But it's not this is a real guy apparently
Speaker 2: says, hey, here, I got air
coming through. It's air purification system
from 3M. OK, this is what you wear in an outbreak.
This is what you wear. If this was so bad. OK,
so I have a little girl that comes to my
house every day last year. They all got
Speaker 1: suspicious, by the way.
Shouldn't that be investigated? A
little girl is coming to his house every day.
Speaker 2: That was great. Everybody went back.
And that's your choice. We all went back. We
all were misplaced here. Right? Everything
went smoothly. That was fine. But now the
years change. Numbers got better. Right.
Numbers got better in June, July. So in June,
we passed we passed that the safety program
where it was going to be optional. So let's go
back to optional if the numbers are there and
everything's low and let's go back to optional
because my kids going in the sixth grade,
you know, sixth grade teacher Spanish, OK,
remember taking a language in the high school,
remember taking language?
Speaker 1: Oh, dangerous
languages are being taught in grade school.
Speaker 2: You need to see the teachers math.
You need to see the expression. So guess what
happens if my daughter goes to take Spanish
and she can't see the teacher teacher, the mouth
movements, they don't learn. So guess what? We
fall under and I'll give you a history.
Speaker 1: No, that's the one reasonable
thing my mom teaches teaches Spanish in
college and she has pointed out, you know,
it is very difficult if you're trying to teach
Spanish to non-native speakers and if they're
native speakers, they already speak Spanish. If
you're trying to teach people Spanish who are
learning it as a second language, the mask does
make it difficult in lots of schools are saying,
well, the students are all going to wear masks.
The teacher can be far away and not wearing them
out. That's a that's a relatively minor issue.
Speaker 2: 1990. No, what those mask,
those masks caused bronchial pneumonia. That's
what killed most people in the Spanish flu.
A third of all. Let's get back to the kids. OK,
bye, little girl next door, a friend of mine,
she was in my house for three days, went
back to school. Guess what she had covered.
Speaker 1: All right. So there's this guy.
Next clip is from Fort Myers, Florida.
And this is this is another one of these
ideas that the masks will facilitate sex
trafficking. We heard this last week, by the way.
Speaker 7: How are you doing when he's Brian
Biggs, Biggs, Biggs, not Briggs? I want to talk
about the real pandemic, child sex trafficking.
If I put mass on these kids face, you can't
identify any of them. Yeah. So by the nine of you
already voting on this tells me
you guys support sex trafficking,
Speaker 3: etc., you're out of order.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we heard that last week as well,
which is like a really specific thing,
which is you can't identify the kidnapers
if everybody's wearing masks. Why are the
kidnapers in schools at all and what's going
on in the schools? That's another question.
And then here's an example of how everything is
always a conspiracy. This is video from a live
feed of the Lee County School Board meeting.
And the guy shows up and says there is a
conspiracy not to stream the meeting, but
we saw it on the feed. It's always a conspiracy.
Speaker 7: Was the live feed that's typically done
for these events is down? Did you know that? Oh,
no one can seem to find it. Why would that be?
It was by accident. Of
course we know that. I mean,
seriously, we know disinfectant.
Sunlight is a great disinfectant
and we know when stuff like this
Speaker 1: is brought to light. I
think he's mentioning that metaphorically. I
know that with Trump suggesting disinfectant,
you actually have to be. Are we talking about a
metaphorical disinfectant or a literal here? He's
talking about a metaphorical one. It will get
Speaker 7: fizzle, though, and die. And I know
that's what you're trying to hide here, but.
Speaker 1: Oh, wait a sec. Now, I'm wondering,
is he literally talking about sunlight as a
disinfectant now? I'm not sure. In any case,
it's always a conspiracy somehow. It's always
a conspiracy. Now, it's not only that they want
to put masks on kids in school, but they want to
prevent people from finding out. So they've taken
down the live feed. Of course, we all saw this
on the live feed. It's either comet ping pong
or Obama isn't real or he's a Muslim. Now it's
masks and vaccines. These people will always find
something. And it's the conspiracy ism that is
partially the illness. There's also actual mental
illness. And then there's also ignorance. How do
we deal with this? Quite frankly, I don't know